so when did you start learning english
then i guess it started from
high school i mean like we had english
school yeah like an airman to school or
middle school but or we were there
who people know me drop it i've noticed
yeah yeah like we don't know when to use
english
but then i got into wwe
really really yeah wwf
you know oh my god
you just keep speaking okay
i was just used to like naturally
watching
japanese professional wrestling okay
because my dad was a physician for
that like japanese wrestling federation
or
that organization so it was just natural
for me to watch
professional wrestlings and yeah
and then you got into it from that like
they came to japan
oh okay so they had a tour in japan that
was actually the second time like they
took a tour
i couldn't make it in the first time i
think the first time
they still had rock i was like oh my god
that's going way back
that's going so far one influencer in
the world
by the way i guarantee there's like a
group of like really young people
watching this all like
the rock
yeah yeah exactly i just imagine like
you younger just going around can you
smell with the rocks
that's like your first like sentence
oh my god i remember in high school when
uh or in like uh
middle school when people would just say
that and just immediately fart
it's just
yeah yeah there's like can you smell
what the rock is cooking and
it was just like it was just like a joke
and everyone started doing it it was so
[ __ ] annoying that's
hilarious joey's like damn i gotta write
that yeah
it's a new joke so wait so you got into
wwf
at the time yes that stage i saw
triple h was actually the star the
champion
[Applause]
i'm not going to mention that but yeah
let's keep it a secret yeah
i want to stay mysterious
so yeah triple h just came out i was in
the front row but very close to front
row so i could just
feel actually his water thrashing
wow wow so you were you were in the
splash zone yeah
wow you could smell what he was cooking
wait splashing water like sweat what oh
no he does this
i don't know if he's still doing it
right right like he just put water in
his mouth
when he comes out yeah yeah yeah i
remember as a kid i used to try and i
begged my parents to buy me like the
wrestling you know like
action figure yeah no no connor that's
that's got three zeros we're not
yeah i never got into wrestling i mean
like
uh my uh my uncle was like a pretty big
fan my japanese uncle's like a pretty
big fan of the japanese wrestling side
yeah but i don't know i never like
really
said i know if i sit down and watch it
though i think i'd love it i mean it
just it just seems like anime
with real people yeah and amazingly like
the the only thing i know about
wrestling is from super eye patch wolf's
videos about wrestling that's pretty
much
my knowledge on wrestling yeah yeah no
it seems like something i could probably
get into if i
had the time to commit to it because it
seems like a lot of fun yeah
isn't it just like a basically just a
pantomime but in like
basically it's a stage performance right
yeah it's like a theatrical yeah
exactly kind of like a final fight with
a drummer yeah
you like what you enjoy hacker like
doing a lot of stuff
yeah yeah exactly because that's like
because it's all coordinated right yeah
it's
yeah yeah as far as i know and i think
they're very famous moments where are
they because i remember seeing
my recommended like top 10 ad libs in
wrestling yeah
something i can't think about what was
the athlete i caught what it was it was
like someone meant to slam the table but
he slammed his face
and i was like oh [ __ ]
coming up next on watch mojo
so did you ever think about i think
there's gonna be a weird question but
did you ever think about
i want to be a wrestler or like did you
ever think about like going into that
side of things
not really because yeah i just wanted to
like
get to know them but that's it like
maybe
become a physician like my dad or you
know maybe a translator i don't know
but so it's basically like us with anime
where we we saw anime we saw it's in
japanese so that was
our motivation to learn japanese for
anyone who did at that age
well we didn't want to go into the anime
industry we just wanted to talk about it
yeah exactly right yeah yeah i'm i don't
have a physical for pro wrestling
obviously
i'm like i don't know if you guys can
tell but i'm very short because
compared to these the huge i don't think
i'm that dude
i don't know how tall my audience think
i am because everyone assumes i'm really
short yeah the first comment i always
get
is man you're a lot taller than my
friend thing in real life i hate people
like i thought you were
taller yeah i'm like what [ __ ] it might
just be like
the white man an asian man right like
it's like oh he's asian so he must be
short oh he's white so he must be tall
yeah i remember when we aired our akiba
video and
everyone the all the comments were i
can't believe god's taller than connor
my image is shattered for some reason
i'm like six foot ten
like i don't know why people think that
like just a normal guy
leave me alone stop bullying me so wait
so you got into
wwf yeah right
you don't really wanna learn language
from them you know like you know
i don't know i'd be fantastic if i met a
japanese person who spoke like a wwe
i don't see that i try not to say it i
just realized like everyone everything
they say is so like anti-japanese
culture
it's so in your face and that's so
opposite although to be fair if a
japanese person came up to me and said
do you smell what the rock is cooking
i'd be like dude you are awesome
i love you then
you got me you got me